[Music]  everybody at Dancing with the Stars  having babies getting married like it's  it's full fun your time we talk about it  it's it's definitely from the cards yeah  Emma Slater and Sasha Farber are  officially married you just perfect just  the Dancing with the Stars pros got  engaged on live TV in October 2016 et  was with the pair right after Emma said  yes you want a casual more chilled I  feel like that reflects us as people we  don't even know where we would have it  yet but definitely and more just like a  party for everybody just a celebration  and that's what we think it should be a  week later Emma told ET their wedding  party will include many of our favorite  famous faces Britney Lindsay Whitney  you've got a plan  Alfonzo war Tom Bergeron MC how cool  would that be maybe one can officiate  one could be sheet one can yes oh wow  that's a party right yeah it's gonna be  I mean they're all our best friends  [Music]  [Applause]